les forces russes de l'ôter essais qui
se retireront après leur mission c'est
ce qu'a déclaré vladimir poutine le
président russe a participé ce matin une
réunion extraordinaire du conseil de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective pour en parler on retrouve en
direct de moscou notre correspondante
maëlys d'estrées
balises bonjour la visioconférence de
l'hôtesse est consacrée à la situation
au kazakhstan vient de s'achever que
faut-il en retenir
bonjour doha effectivement cette
visioconférence des dirigeants kazakhs
tanner biélorusse russes arméniens
kirghizes et tadjik vient de s'achever
au cours de celle ci le président kazakh
astana a dénoncé une tentative de coup
d'état perpétrée par des combattants
armés d'après kassim jomart tokayev ceux
ci auraient profité de manifestations
contre la hausse du prix du gaz pour
tenter de renverser le pouvoir le chef
d'état a en outre assuré que ses forces
ne tirerai jamais sur les manifestants
pacifiques
les exigences politiques et sociales ont
commencé à
passer en deuxième et troisième à un
plan et maintenant nous avons vu
apparaître des groupes de terroristes
et pour nous la butte et principal est
devenu évident ceal la dissolution et la
prise du pouvoir avec la destruction du
pouvoir parce qu'il s'agit d'une
tentative de coup d'état
d'après kassim jeu marteau kiev l'ordre
constitutionnel a été rétablie dans le
pays et les 2300 soldats de maintien de
la paix déployées par le tfc se
retireront prochainement au cours de son
intervention vladimir poutine a quant à
lui souligné que la russie ne tolérerait
pas de révolution de couleur en ex urss
et que le kazakhstan avait été visée par
le terrorisme international hippiques
dans cette menace pour la stabilité de
l'état il y avait donc des actes isolés
de délinquance mais il y avait surtout
le fait que des forces intérieures et
extérieures profitait de ces troubles
il y a ceux qui étaient qui se servaient
de protestation des contestations liées
aux augmentations de prix du gaz c'est
une chose et c'est une autre chose que
ce qui
provoquait des pogroms et que des
destructions il est très important que
notre organisation
par la voix du secrétaire général a su
prendre des décisions
en pleine concertation et qui sans même
temps très strictes et ans je tiens à
préciser qu'en quelques heures nous
avons réussi à nous mettre d'accord au
niveau des autorités nationales pour
éviter une dégradation de la situation
dans l'ensemble du pays et à mettre fin
aux pillages et aux actions violentes
commises par ces terroristes et je
rappelle que ce 6 janvier moscou a
envoyé des soldats dans le cadre de la
force de maintien de la paix déployées
par le tc est demandée par le kazakhstan
à l'instar des contingents arménien
biélorusse et tadjik également dépêchés
sur place les unités surveille les sites
militaires et gouvernementaux importants
et viennent en aide aux forces de
l'ordre locales à la suite des troubles
de ces derniers jours le kazakhstan
déplore actuellement plus d'une centaine
de morts et plus d'un millier de blessés
malisse à l'espoir en direct de moscou
merci pour toutes ces précisions